one of the examples that I've seen new
atheist types you could call them or you
know rationalist types used to criticize
religion has been to criticize the evil
eye and that the evil eye is this
example of superstition and you know
kind of silly magical thinking which
which think that somehow someone can
look at you and can affect you can have
this effect on you by by looking at you
in a certain way you know almost like in
a magical manner and just how silly that
is and how it's silly for people to to
be worried about that and to think about
that in traditional cultures and so I
thought that you know in my opinion in
my thought the evil eye is actually
something which is quite obvious to
understand and so hopefully I can give
you a little bit of an explanation of
what that might be
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
problem the problem of understanding a
lot of traditional thinking and really
just thinking is something that I've
been trying to explain to my channel for
quite a while now and the problem is the
rationalists approach to reality and
let's say the kind of Enlightenment
approach reality which is to remove the
viewer from causality which is to
completely act as if we are not part of
the causal links in the world and so
once you start to reintegrate the the
conscious agent or the viewer into the
relationships of causality and you start
to see that that is inevitable then what
happens is that the your perception of
how causality works is going to slightly
change especially in in terms of human
interactions and human life and so when
you hear someone who to me it's a it's
almost a surprise to hear someone talk
about how silly it is to think that
someone can destroy you by looking at
you in a certain manner that someone
could cause misfortune in your life by
looking at you in a certain manner I
often think that people who who can't
see that that's possible are people who
maybe don't live in communities people
who don't have families maybe because in
a world where everybody is connected and
I can understand because we do live in a
world where communities are falling
apart where we live in these anonymous
suburbs in these anonymous cities but in
a world where people are linked together
where everybody knows each other and
everybody talks about each other then
then the notion that you can destroy
someone by looking at them in a certain
manner all of a sudden starts to take on
a little bit more meaning and so what
I'm going to try to do is I'm going to
try to give you analogies to maybe help
you understand how something like the
evil I can
work now it is it is difficult for us to
completely understand because we are we
do live in a world that is materialistic
in a world that is disconnected and
communities that are disconnected but
hopefully this will help you to kind of
get a glimpse of what something like the
evil eye could be and how the mechanisms
of causality could function in such a
such a trope let's especially such a
social trope let's say now the most
simple example is to look in your own
life and to notice those moments where
the manner in which someone looked at
you
does in fact bring you at least small
misfortune now a good example is I'm
sure everybody has experienced the going
into a store and going up to to a clerk
or to someone who's working there and
the person looking at you with just
utter contempt and giving you that that
look like you are absolutely nothing now
for some people not for everybody but
for some people that can seriously
affect them and it can affect them for
hours on end it can affect them for a
whole day
it could affect them for quite it could
cause us a mental obsession which makes
you think about that person and think
about well you know what they did you
the way they looked at you now bring
that now closer within your circle
imagine someone you love imagine your
spouse imagine your your parents look at
you in a certain manner you know and
look at you with contempt but imagine
that you you you could tell you could
make it into a technique and you could
you could do it it could be pretty
powerful you can make it into a
technique where you would actually
consciously look at someone you know
with a cold contempt look and then act
as if you're not doing it now that would
be even more powerful you could have an
even more effect on someone if you did
that you look at them with contempt and
then you say something oh no no
everything's fine no no no I love you
you know and then you can utterly start
to destroy someone now this is the
problem
the problem is that we don't we don't
see that that you know your misfortune
is also caused by your interactions with
other people that the man in which you
interact by other people will and can
bring you to experience misfortune and
living in in a relationship let's say
with someone who would do that to you
who would look at you in a certain way
who would pretend that they're not doing
it who act as if you know they they they
they would say they love you but look at
you with utter contempt constantly that
could make you sick it could make you
you know lose your job it could make you
you know start to to to be distracted
could call maybe you could have a car
accident because of that because you're
distracted because you're taken up by
this this disturbing this disturbing
fact in your life now the type of
causality is not the same type as the
scientists would want because there is
no there is no you can't measure the
atoms between someone in your life
acting and looking at you with utter
content let's say and the car accident
you would have because as you're driving
you're you're distracted by what's
happening and because you're distracted
by what's happening maybe you're
struggling in your job maybe you're
having financial problems and all of
that is racking up and building up to a
point where you're crossing you're
you're turning on the light and smash
into a car and but there is a causality
between all of those things it's just
not the same type of causality now
the examples that I'm using are our
psychological let's say they are some
that we can understand in a more
immediate manner let's say because we
still have access to it but imagine a
society imagine a human society which
would have four generations after
generations millennia after millennia
refined the art of looking refined the
art of looking at someone in a manner
that will have an effect on it an effect
on that person now to say that that's
impossible is is to me is just crazy
because it not only is it possible we
have these types of Sciences in other
aspects for example you can imagine
someone imagine someone like Marilyn
Monroe who has completely mastered the
art of seduction who has completely
mastered the art of looking at a man in
a certain manner in order to attract
that man's attention in order to get
into that person's head and affect them
and you'll find people con artists who
will be able by the way they they look
at you by the way they interact with you
in very very subtle subtle terms will be
able to gain your trust in order to then
go in and destroy your life now we can
see that let's say in in terms of
seduction we understand because we see
people who do it we see people in movies
we see people you know we have stories
of men who who are able to seduce seduce
many many women just with very very
subtle techniques they don't actually
care about those people they don't they
don't they only see it almost as a game
that they're playing in order to have
power and to have effect on others now
imagine the same thing happening in a
culture but in a negative way that is
that someone could master the art of
effecting people negatively with with a
a look with a man or a man in which they
they look at you and they know that if
they do it in a certain manner not only
will it affect you but then other people
will notice that you are doing that to
them and then and then it will create a
chain of causality around you in your in
your community which will slowly
bring you down and which which could
destroy your life you know one way or
the other and so so so so let's look
let's and and the problem is that it's
very difficult to describe these
scientifically some of these techniques
are very very subtle they're they're
they're extremely difficult to quantify
a good way to understand that is to
understand for example hypnotism
the capacity someone can have to
hypnotize someone else now if you just
take if you just read a article on how
to hypnotize someone and then you try to
hypnotize yourself you probably will not
be able to do it you will you would have
to have learned from someone who is
capable of doing it and you would pick
up these subtle signs these these subtle
manners of acting just like for example
it's probably very difficult to learn to
sell something just by reading a book on
how to sell but being in contact with
someone who's a very good salesman will
help you pick up these very very subtle
cues that will make you into a good
salesman or will make you into a good
hypnotist and so in the same manner a
such a skill as you know the capacity to
affect someone with with a look you know
it's not difficult to imagine that that
could appear in a culture and become a
prominent aspect of a culture and that
it wouldn't have an effect especially
like I said in a culture that is tightly
knitted and the connection between
everybody are real now people will say
yeah but you're just cycle looks like a
son you know making it psychological and
and you're just you know you're trying
to explain away the magical aspect of it
but the problem is that people I think
most people don't understand what magic
is or how magic was perceived in
traditional cultures we have a kind of
weird materialist vision of how what
what magical skills are what that would
have been in traditional cultures and in
traditional cultures it was
in for example in the middle-ages magic
was not seen as necessarily something
which was evil or a cult or whatever it
was just seen as the a manner in which
to interact with reality a manner in
which to affect reality and if it was
bad it was bad because you could use
that man that that skill like you could
use seduction like you could use the
capacity to hypnotize someone you could
use that skill to cause damage and so
that was the problem with the way that
that magic was like it was bad magic
which was a problem using subtle skills
subtle human capacity to affect the
world in a negative way now one of the
things then that that I need to explain
for example is the the protection
talisman and so people who try to ward
off the evil eye and will wear a
talisman to ward to ward them off and
you'll say well that's just silly
why would wearing some type if what
you're saying the evil eye is what
you're saying it is then why would
wearing a talisman of the evil eye
ward off that type of interaction and
the answer is I can give you the answer
by explaining it this way
you you want someone to do well at at an
interview and you you want them to to
succeed what do you tell them you say
wear a suit wear a tie dress up wear
something that's going to make you sit
straight right and then you'll have a
better chance of getting the job and you
think well what does that have to do
with anything what if your job what if
the job has nothing to do with the way
you dress or the way you comport
yourself what if your job is sitting in
in an office typing on a computer why
would you wear a suit that has there's
no there's no material causality between
you wearing a suit for an interview and
you getting the job but see once again
there's this ignorance if you wear a
suit you will be conscious that you are
wearing this suit you will be aware of
how you are dressed facing the person in
front of you it is it is creating that
awareness of
your presentation to the other which is
what will make you more conscious of how
you present yourself more conscious of
how you speak more conscious of how the
person is responding to you now the
notion of wearing a talisman is the same
thing that is if you wear a talisman
against the evil eye it is because you
are conscious of the evil eye that is
you are making yourself aware that this
is possible and you're also making
yourself aware that you do not want to
be influenced in that manner but you're
not just signaling it to to yourself if
you wear a pendant with a talisman for
example you're also signaling it to
everybody around you maybe to the person
who who wants to destroy you but then
also to the people around you which are
part of that network of connections and
so that signaling is a signaling which
will to a certain extent block the
capacity that the person has to affect
you because you're making you're making
yourself and you're making other people
aware that this dynamic is is going on
in and I do not want it to affect me and
so the type of causality is a different
type of causality and say and and the
problem is that it is also not because
it's not quantifiable you could wear a
talent to protect yourself from the evil
eye and then you could it could not work
that's totally possible just like you
could wear a suit to go to an interview
to help yourself present yourself better
and to be more straight and then but
then you could overcome that and your
slobby
self and your your your kind of chaotic
you know incapacity to present yourself
is going to be stronger than your
talisman that you're wearing in that
interview but it doesn't mean that it
that it that it doesn't help and that
it's not part of the structure you know
just because it doesn't work all the
time does it mean that it's not
something that
if you do can have an effect on these
types of interactions and so you know we
and and so there are many many ways that
we do that you know today someone who
for example someone who for example
doesn't want to I don't know who doesn't
want to watch porn on their computer who
doesn't want to drink who doesn't want
to who doesn't want to to do certain
things you can and it can help you to
have signs signifiers that you wear on
yourself something to remind you
something that acts as a little barrier
towards that behavior that you want to
stop you can have all kinds of little
things that you can do to kind of help
you are those things impervious no of
course not they're not but can they help
yes they can and it's really that type
of understanding that you can you can
see I'll give you a very good example
that I had went through myself you know
I kind of I gotta come from a punk rock
teenage existence and you can see I kind
of have long hair sometimes I have it
even longer it's tied because I know I
don't work for anybody I work for myself
and have a beard and everything and for
very long time I would I love to wear
linen when I'm traveling because you
know it's very it's very comfortable you
don't need a belt you wear linen pants
without a belt you can wear a linen
shirt it's very nice and comfortable
it's a one day I went on an airplane and
I had long hair I had pulled it in a
ponytail and I was wearing all linen
clothing and I went up to the security
and the security guard pulled me aside
and I was like what's going on and then
I heard him on his his walkie-talkie he
told he said I've got a Rambler I was
like what a Rambler what the heck is
that and so they came and they searched
my bag and they made me touch this
little thing and then it's like I
realized it what they they thought is
that I probably have
and I probably have and someone because
of the way I'm dressed because I'm
wearing linen because I have long hair
because I have a beard all of that
together makes it look you know like I'm
a patchouli wearing hippy that probably
has drugs in their back and so the
manner in which I dressed the type of
things that I was wearing had a
causality in my life it was affecting my
life and and you know that to be true
you tell someone you see someone where
who has neck tattoos or he has facial
tattoos and you think that is going to
seriously affect your existence in the
negative sense but you can the same
thing can be in the in the positive
sense
for example Coptic Christians would
tattoo a cross on their arm and you
would think okay so why would they do
that well there are plenty of reasons
why they would do that you could and if
you ask them they might say something
like it is a protection I put the cross
on my hand to protect me and you'll say
oh that's just you know easiest
superstitious of course it's just
superstition
then why would putting a cross on your
on your hand protect you
why would doing the sign of the Cross
protect you and so imagine now that that
Coptic Christian is in a situation where
there's pressure and there is right now
in Egypt pressure for you to convert to
Islam pressure for you to let's say
compromise on what you believe and on
your faith now that thing is marked on
your skin you have a cross on your skin
and so if you do compromise your
yourself and you do compromise would you
believe if you convert to Islam through
social pressure or you are you you do
something of the like then you will have
this burning mark on your hand to
constantly remind you of what what you
did and so the mark act as a protection
it does it literally does act as a
protection it protects you it protects
you from going in certain directions
from certain things
let's say happening to you now is it is
it possible to surmount that is it
possible to break that that that
protection is possible to still convert
to Islam yes of course it is but just
because it's not it doesn't help you in
100 percent of the times does it mean
that it also that it doesn't help you
that it can't help you if to you it's
important to remain faithful to what you
believe okay so yeah so I think I'm Way
past explaining the evil eye and I'm
just I'm now I'm basically explaining
the whole whole systems of how these
types of of causalities can work and how
they're not they're not they're not the
same types of causalities that
scientists like to look at but they they
exist nonetheless and everybody I know
engages in those types of causalities by
the way they dress by the way they
present themselves and then also can
have effect on others by the way they
they say certain things by the way they
they use passive aggressive behavior or
whatever it is you can affect someone
else's life and and you don't have to
see that as superstitious all right so I
hope you enjoyed this discussion yeah
and I will see you soon if you enjoyed
this content and our exploration of
symbolism get involved I love to read
your insights and questions in the
comment section you can also share this
video on social media to your friends
and as you can please consider
supporting us financially through
patreon or PayPal you'll find those
links in the description below